a longtime ally of US President Donald
Trump has been provisionally released
from custody after being arrested this
morning Roger stone paid a two hundred
and fifty thousand dollar bond and will
face travel restrictions now he's been
charged with obstruction of justice
witness tampering and making false
statements a stone was an advisor to
Donald Trump during the 2016 election
campaign and the charges stem from u.s.
Special Counsel Robert Miller and his
investigation into whether the Trump
campaign colluded with Russia in the
election now stone denies the charges
here's what he said I will plead not
guilty to these charges I will defeat
them in court I believe this is a
politically motivated investigation I am
troubled by the political motivations of
prosecutors and as I have said
previously there is no circumstance
whatsoever under which I will bear false
witness against the president nor will I
make up lies to ease the pressure on
myself
[Music]
GWS Maya shweder is on the story for us
in Washington and she joins us now hi
Maya what else can you tell us about
what exactly Roger stone is being
charged with here so there are now seven
counts against him including lying to
congressional investigators attempted a
witness tampering and possible
obstruction of justice so these are just
three things that look very similar to
what other people in Trump's orbit who
have also now been charged with crimes
have been charged with all again related
to goings on during the 2016 US
presidential campaign so this is Roger
stone we have to remember it was one of
the closest people in Trump's orbit one
thing that Trump and the White House has
been able to do so far is say this
person who's been charged wasn't really
part of the campaign
I didn't really know this person this
person was only involved for a few
months Roger stone also was only
involved in the Trump campaign for a few
months but he has been a close associate
of President Trump for decades and the
White House is already attempting to try
to wave this off as something that's not
related to the White House but that is
much harder to do in this case Maya who
is Roger stone then what is his
background Roger stone has been a
background player in the US political
scene for decades he actually worked for
the Richard Nixon campaign for people
watching who might not know who Richard
Nixon is he was a not very beloved
president in the 1970s who ultimately
was impeached and resigned over charges
of obstruction of justice by Roger stone
remained very loyal to Richard Nixon and
it said that he even has a tattoo of
Richard Nixon's face on his back so he
has been involved with conservative
politics in the US for decades and again
has been a close associate of President
Trump for a very long time both he and
Paul Manafort another former campaign
official on the Trump campaign were
close associates in the 1980s they were
top of the game in terms of foreign
lobbying so he also is in Trump's inner
circle and his arrest today his
appearance before court means that
whatever investigations are going on now
they're getting much closer to the
president yeah Maya that is the question
what does the fallout here for president
Trump what we've seen today so far is
the White House singing their usual song
of there's been no collusion proven here
this has nothing to do with the
president and the thing that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the press secretary
said today was all of these people
who've been arrested and charged and
indicted yes they all were maybe in the
president's orbit at some point but they
were all arrested on charges that have
nothing to do with the president and the
thing is she's not wrong but what she's
painting is a picture of a candidate
during the campaign who was somewhat
disconnected
from his campaign stash he claims that
he had no knowledge of the goings-on of
what Roger stone was doing no knowledge
of this now a legendary meeting at Trump
Tower between the president sound the
president's son-in-law and this Russian
lawyer in which alleged possible
collusion was discussed which isn't a
good look for the president so the more
he tries to pull back from all these
people around him who are getting nabbed
by the feds really just the worse it
looks for him
all right DWS maia shweder following the
story for us in Washington Maya thank
you very much